[Musique]
bonjour jacky le portier bonjour
monsieur vous êtes coordinateur de la
république ici en martinique de la
république en marche le mouvement qui
est au pouvoir dans l'hexagone jacky le
courtier on vous découvre coordinateur
on a entendu parler de référents un
moment on entendu de nom officiel pour
cette fonction mathieu ghamari copette
on a vu ensuite une foultitude de
petites abeilles venant tourner
brusquement autour du gros pot de miel
on va faire court qui est le patron dans
marche ici en martinique patron c'est un
grand mot aussi vous voulez aujourd'hui
il ya un coordinateur que je suis et il
y a eu des référents n'y en a plus il va
y en avoir dans quelques semaines très
court une semaine ou deux mais
aujourd'hui le représentant dans marche
c'est moi points comment comment êtes
vous devenu coordinateur parce que
beaucoup de personnes se sont
autoproclamés chef de file de ceux de ce
mouvement présidentiel
le retour proclamait je suis pas sûr que
le mot soit bon puisque effectivement
quand vous me parlez de monsieur gamma
et de monsieur copette ils ont
effectivement été nommé par la
république en marche sa part en marche à
l'époque puisque c'était pas la
république en marche ont été nommé
coordinateur et on leur a retiré ses
fonctions voilà donc ça existe et il n'y
a pas de problème
moi je l'étais à la demande de monsieur
coop est c'est à dire que monsieur
copette a demandé à l'époque quand il
était référent que je sois le
coordinateur et j'ai été nommé par paris
coordinateur monsieur kopechne et ont pu
référent il ne reste plus que le
coordinateur donc je dois assumer la
totalité des responsabilités pour
l'instant comment se structure la
république en marche dans notre île on
parle de deux comités on parle de deux
sympathisants on parle de deux contacts
on parle de on a du mal à voir comment
ça se passe ce niveau oui c'est c'est
pas un une organisation classique d'un
parti c'est à dire que c'est un
mouvement déjà où il n'ya pas de
cotisations donc tout le monde peut
adhérer monsieur le temps vous pouvez
adhérer
j'aurais d'ailleurs content de devoir
recevoir mais
donc on a deux types effectivement de
marcheurs on a des contacts ce sont des
gens qui ont envie d'avoir des
informations de la part d' en marche
paris et nous avons des militants
ce qu'on appelle des marcheurs et le
marché local et donc c'est une
distinction très importante parce que le
coordinateur que je suis peut s'adresser
aux marcheurs mais n'a pas possibilité
d'avoir un contact avec les contacts
vous avez parlé de la nomination de
référents dans dans les tout prochains
jours pourquoi s'attarde autant pourquoi
on a l'impression que c'est une
mayonnaise qui ne prend pas ici dans
notre île
c'est à cause de tous ces bruits qu'on a
entendues autour de marche
on a parlé de derrick copette de mathieu
gamin mais il ya également fred lordinot
daniel chomet chantal mignon alors vous
faire le dise la distinguo entre deux
catégories
vous avez eu deux référents que j'ai
cités et vous avez ensuite des
personnalités que vous venez de donner
daniel robin daniel robin donc ces
personnalités vous avez daniel robin qui
est marcheurs chantal maignan qui et
marcheuses puis pas très longtemps mais
qui et marcheuses et vous avez frais de
lordinot même est à marcheuse pour les
élections législatives ben non elle
n'était pas marcheuses et non non non
non elle n'était pas marcheuse à
l'époque mais elle a eu l'investiture
bon voilà je ne reviendrai pas dessus
mais c'est une vénus et une convaincue
de 2,2 de la politique du président de
la république elle le défend aujourd'hui
avec beaucoup d'acharnement et l'a
d'ailleurs depuis qu'elle et marcheuses
elle a créé un comité au robert alors
ces comités
c'est quoi exactement dans la combi en
martinique alors les comités il ya là
plusieurs si vous voulez vous avez six
comités validé aujourd'hui et vous avez
en instance de validation vous en avais
13 c'est à dire que les comités au
démarrage ont été créés sur des sur un
petit peu si vous voulez par rapport aux
législative sur sur la circonscription
pour coller avec l'actualité et
aujourd'hui bon légistatives étant
passée l'objectif d'en marche martinique
et d'avoir un comité par ville
donc nous nous y attelons et c'est pour
ça que nous ne nous en avons six
actuellement en cours de validation
pourquoi en cours de validation c'est
important de préciser ça veut dire que
vous pouvez vous déclarez demandé à être
responsable d'un comité met quand même
en marche en métropole regarde quand
même qu'ils demandent et est ce que
j'essaie d'être regardant sur qui
demande croît airs morphiniques
regardant il ya un minimum si vous
voulez on voudrait même on sait que dans
les partis politiques il y à des espions
partout donc on essaye quand même
d'éviter des psychodrames on avait
suffisamment vécu en martinique pour ne
pas en rajouter
vous êtes combien en martinique alors on
est 759 contact comme vous disiez à
juste titre et nous sommes 676 marcheurs
des marcheurs qui devront porter la
parole manuel macron et de son premier
ministre edouard philippe
vous avez vu que le dialogue passe très
très mal par exemple entre ce mouvement
présidentiel et les régions qui viennent
de claquer la porte
orléans lors de ce congrès des régions
tout simplement parce que en marche
n'arrive pas à comprendre qu'on demande
trop collectivités notamment en termes
d'efforts à faire pour économiser de
l'argent
oui je pense que là vous vous soulevez
un vrai problème
je pense qu'on ne peut pas faire ce que
veut faire emmanuel macron une
transformation du pays
sans remettre en cause un certain nombre
de deux choses
et vous savez on est dans un pays où
tout le monde est d'accord avec les
réformes à condition qu'ils ne soient
pas concernés
et je crois que les présidents de région
aujourd'hui effectivement ils défendent
leur région ils ont raison moi je peux
le comprendre localement ce serait la
même chose mais à un moment donné
est-ce qu'on veut oui ou non que le pays
res s'améliore et pouvoir redonner un
petit peu de pouvoir d'achat aux
salariés et je pense que c'est important
et si on ne fait pas d'économies on n'y
arrivera pas alors puisque vous avez
suivi très attentivement ces dernières
élections sénatoriales c'est à dimanche
dernier tous les candidats ont eu au
moins un point de convergence c'est
cette baisse des dotations allouées aux
collectivités ils n'ont pas les moyens
de faire autrement
ils ne peuvent pas accepter cette idée
qu'on réduise encore à les dotations de
l'état aux collectivités qui pousse sur
qui pouvait vous comptez pour porter
cette parole ici en martinique vous en
marche ici alors moi je suis assez
d'accord avec les pour la martinique je
suis assez d'accord qu'il faut prendre
en compte la spécificité de la
martinique
là je suis tout à fait d'accord et je
pense que notre travail ça fait ça va
être de faire remonter à l'état que nous
sommes pas une région comme les autres
nous sommes insulaire nous avons des
difficultés au niveau de l'emploi est
aujourd'hui si les collectivités n'y
arrive plus et parce que ils ont fait
aussi du social au niveau de l'emploi
faut reconnaître quand vous avez une
moyenne en métropole en frais de
personnel qui représentent environ 40 à
45 % du budget de fonctionnement
il ya plus de 60 à 70 % en martinique
donc ça veut dire que les maires ont
joué leur rôle social et que l'état n'en
a pas tenu compte
mais depuis trente ans on pas depuis
quatre mois ils ont leurs ouailles est
et vous croyez que d'autres régions
françaises accepteront qu'on en fasse
une exception pour la martinique eh bien
écoutez moi je je pense que la
solidarité de l'outre-mer elle doit être
au niveau national je pense que quand on
aura compris que l'outre-mer est un plus
pour la république française je pense
qu'on peut être capable de l'accepter
et vous avez vu ce qui le courtier qui
manuel macro mais cela ne l'a pas
compris lorsque lui et son équipe
annonce comme ça la fin des contrats
aidés dans nos régions vous avez vu ça
donnait 15 jours de mobilisation dans
les rues à fort de france alors là aussi
je suis d'accord et je suis d'accord
avec la ministre de l'outre-mer quand
elle dit je l'entendais tout à l'heure
quand elle dit que c'est une boulette
je pense que emmanuel macron l'a compris
mais vous savez l'administration
centrale c'est quelque chose de terrible
entre la décision de que peut prendre un
ministre ou un président de la
république et quand l'information
redescend parce que ce qu'il faut quand
même dire c'est que le premier ministre
avait signé un document disant que
l'outre-mer ne serait pas concernée par
par cette mesure mais la machine
infernale de l'administration a fait que
ont l'âge est concerné le chalenge
l'enjeu pour la république un marché
actions martinique c'est de faire
remonter ce genre d'informations très
vite pour éviter des boulettes de la
part du gouvernement et on l'a fait
alors vous savez le très vite dix jours
c'est beaucoup
on l'a fait et je les fais
personnellement maintenant je pense
jamais que comme dit à son pouvoir de
prendre son téléphone et d'appeler
manuellement contenant demandé au
premier ministre demande aux préfets de
rectifier le tir vous allez c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe
j'ai le pouvoir j'ai des correspondants
en métropole qui ont eu des contacts
avec les ministères et avec le président
de la république puisque vous savez
qu'en marche il y a eu beaucoup de gens
qui étaient à en marche à l'origine et
qui sont aujourd'hui auprès du président
de la république dont certains je
connais bien sûr puisque ce sont eux
mêmes qui m'ont reçue quels sont les
laits chalenge des les enjeux pour la
république en marche on va déjà parlé
des assises de l'outre-mer est-ce que ça
ça ne risque pas d'être une promesse
présidentielle qui ne verra pas le jour
en tout cas pas de si tôt on attend la
date précise pour ces assises de notre
mère ça se fera ou pas oui ça se fera je
pense à accepter une vraie volonté du
président de la république
maintenant je pense qu'avec ce qui vient
de se passer il est peut-être urgent de
ne pas mettre tout de suite les gens
autour de la table parce que je pense
qu'on risque une petite révolution donc
je pense qu'il faut les préparer
contrairement à ce qui a été fait
auparavant il faut vraiment préparé ces
assises avant de revenir les gens est
donc lancée tout le mandat présidentiel
doit passer non absolument pas alors là
ce serait ce serait dans la cc de
l'humour monsieur viol ton mais j'ose à
peine on connaît bien votre humour mais
non je pense qu'il faut être sérieux
je pense que ça fait quatre mois que le
cinq mois maintenant que le président de
la république est élu
je pense que disons fin d'année début
d'année ce serait quelque chose de très
correct
objectif pour en marche les municipales
2020 puis surtout l'assemblée de
martigues à 2021 voilà vous avez vous
allez très vite
l'objectif il est votre objectif à vous
le l'objectif il est de faire une
implantation et monsieur viol tombe
je pense que vous serez d'accord avec
moi si vous n'avez pas d'élus vous
n'avez pas d'implantation donc il faut
il faut reconnaître qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes un petit peu orphelins nous
n'avons pas d'élu donc nous n'avons pas
d'implantation et si nous n'avons pas
d'à plantations dans l'avenir la
république en marche n'existera pas en
martinique dont vous allez préparer les
municipales 2001 va merci d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin jacky laure thing le
conseiller on rappelle que vous êtes
coordinateur de la république en marche
ici en martinique et qu' il y aura
bientôt un référent ici merci bonne
journée
merci monsieur le temps
[Musique]